this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where that is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice number one best-selling author
ken coleman is my co-host today ramsey
personality sitting along my side here
he is host of the ken coleman show where
they talk about careers and purpose and
jobs and getting one a purpose and a job
and how about mixing them together
that'd be a good idea well he can help
you with all of that so you got
questions about jobs and careers in this
crazy world we live in right now
uh well we're here to help you got
questions about life and money we're
here to help the phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five
you know ken our ratings uh on the show
have gone up substantially during these
wacky times because the um
and i have i have a theory
on this
have you noticed that the world has gone
nuts
yes lost their minds out there
what is wrong with you people
yeah
so i mean yeah it's just uh uh it's a
thing and so and and like we're still
sane and stuff oh yeah like you know
like we believe in like the truth and
the law of gravity still will cause you
to hit the sidewalk when you jump off a
building and stuff like that there are
some things you can believe in that are
true and safe and calm and kindness does
matter
not just anger
and our pulse rate hasn't changed so
people are like why how how come they're
not scared over there at ramsey
solutions how come how come they're not
lost their minds
um because we actually believe in solid
things and teach solid things and so
the great news about the stuff we teach
here whether it's in the career area the
mental health area the marriage area the
money area certainly is it works in
crazy times and it works in regular
times
and so i guess everybody went you know i
need some calmness in my life i need
some stability in my life i need an
anchor that is based on actual facts not
people just making up crap which seems
to be a thing
like you know the old joke was 88
percent of the statistics are made up on
the spot right and so i think it's 98
but it's like right now yeah and 88 of
the science is made up on the spot so um
oh geez there he went and did it i did
it i did it i went there he just did it
i did it so but i mean it's just and
people are lost they're dead kind of
number 11 yeah and you know we could
have said this exact same little rant
right here about
18 months ago and we've still been
accurate but
right now it's just we're we have the
second wave of crazy coming through we
went through the pandemic
and now we're going through the economic
tsunami that is the the delayed you know
when where does a tsunami come from an
earthquake way out in the ocean
so the pandemic was the earthquake way
out in the ocean now we've got supply
chain labor shortages
product shortages hyper inflation
you know stinking if you notice the
price of your gasoline going into your
car five dollars a gallon today in new
york five dollars a gallon and i saw
another headline and they don't even
drive there no they don't they don't uh
you know it's interesting what we talk
about here at ramsey solutions whatever
category that you just listed out the
reality is is that when you've got
discipline when you've got a plan when
the crazy times hit and they will
you don't have to go crazy but everybody
else is going crazy because they weren't
ready for it they don't know what to do
they don't know how to get out of it and
you're right it is a very interesting
time right now where there are some
people dave that are trying to elongate
the panic i got my existential crisis
out of the way about 30 years ago so i'm
kind of i kind of got that one in my
rear view mirror i went ahead and had my
midlife crisis early yeah and so um i
was always an overachiever so raised the
bar so high it's just like yeah i was 27
years old so i mean i went broke lost
everything the kids you know i couldn't
feed the kids and i lost my mind and i
didn't know what i was gonna do and so
that's all kind of back there ways and
so i'm kind of like some of this other
stuff hits i just yawn now i'm like oh
is that all it is here's something i've
i've never asked you on the show and i
want to ask you because it's really
relevant
do you notice a difference between the
headlines and what you see every day we
travel the country uh still
we live here in tennessee
i just see a huge disparity between what
we're being told is going on versus what
i see every day do you sense that well
i've been in five states in 15 days
just recently i mean in the last 15 days
i've been traveling we were doing stuff
with radio i was doing stuff with uh
when i spoke at liberty university and
so um
yeah i i and i'm sad to say
that both sides of the media because
there's not like a media anymore there's
the right media left media
and uh they both lie
all the time
uh if it bleeds it leads
you know and so
i you know the right-hand media is
telling you that you know that you if
you go to california it's all shut down
and the governor is a you know whatever
and the whole the whole thing i went out
to orange county it was like nothing
going on that's what i'm talking walking
around normal and yeah i went to
restaurants and a couple of servers had
masks on but i mean it was about like it
is here in nashville and
you know
fewer rednecks but i mean it's just but
it was um but it was just i mean it was
like i expected based on the news media
to think i was going to russia right you
know the right-hand news media and of
course the left-hand news media would
have you believe that we're all going to
die tomorrow and so you might as well
get you know whatever living you have
left out of the way because friday's
coming and so um but i mean and you know
and i don't see that out there either
that's my point
i i just yeah i quit watching them i i
and some of them a lot of them are
friends of mine that's good and i i just
had to turn them off because as my old
friend zig ziglar used to say he said i
get up every morning i read the bible
read the newspaper so i can tell what
both sides are doing
and so that's so good classic ziggs
classic ziggler but he's right you know
it's like if you took
inputs will screw up your mind yeah and
uh and you join the crazy you join the
fray right i got a friend of mine
watching cnn and fox all right we're
gonna have to put the boy in a rubber
room he's gonna lose it he's gonna he's
it's just gonna well his brain is
draining out of his ears so what you
watch what you listen to
who you listen to who you hang out with
dramatically affect our decisions so
some of this crazy is a result of we're
paying attention to the wrong things
christianity the wrong things yeah it's
like step off the
crazy people are in charge that's the
problem who knew
let's see that's that's the myth too
they're not in charge
i mean there's all kinds of nonsense
going on in dc right now every day well
that's asking yourself how does that
affect your day-to-day life
get off of the crazy merry-go-round and
realize you have a lot to do with you
yeah a lot more than you realize it it
affected me when i went to the gas pump
sure of course it affected me a few
other times but overall
other than that it didn't really affect
me except to the extent i chose to
cram this trashy input into my brain
every day
and then try to exist in a normal world
the only time i got nervous dave was
when the toilet paper got got dicey that
was that was a little scary got up to
the old neighborhood grocery store
couldn't find any toilet paper i just
officially got nervous that was the only
time shook me for about 10 minutes and
then i realized
we'll adjust and then i got over it
aren't you glad i shared that with you
yeah and you have to know that if the
biggest crisis that you've had in your
life
was tp you're blessed you're in pretty
good shape buddy just pretty good shape
i'm just saying that that's everything
daniel boone didn't have tp's and he
made it which is why i adjusted it after
10 minutes davey crockett no tp but he
figured out a way didn't have american
express he left home without it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book the
proximity principle
and author of the new book from paycheck
to purpose it is in pre-sale right now
comes out in a couple of weeks in
november the clear path to doing work
you love from paycheck to purpose if you
buy it now at ramsey solutions while
it's in pre-sale you get the e-book the
audiobook and about a hundred dollars
worth of odds and ends goodies that we
throw in with the book to get you to buy
a pre-sale we bribe you
so come and get you one right now from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
work you love
it'll be ken coleman's second number one
i'm praying and hoping and wishing and
maybe what do you think i you know i
think it's going to do well we didn't
know when we wrote it a year and a half
ago that we were going to come into this
type of an environment and so we think
it's going to help a lot of people um
and and that's what we're praying for is
that it just really
strikes a chord and helps people realize
there is a clear path
55 percent of american workers struggle
with burnout it's real right now if you
want to change jobs this year more than
half of america's workforce are
looking to leave their cruddy jobs so
they can find something better it's
called the great resignation
but before you do that
you need to ask yourself what do i like
about my current job what do i not like
about my current job what does my dream
job look like what do i need to do if i
want to have my dream job don't just
leave for more money that's what paychex
purpose is all about it's exactly right
you know at the end of the day
you want to do work that makes great
income but also tremendous impact to you
that's when you start throwing around
phrases like dream job
well and here's the thing
what you think
is going to make you happy might fool
you
absolutely right
my contention is that a bazillion of
these people that are working from home
are going to find really quickly that
they're lonely
as a matter of fact we're having people
from the technology field
the developers and and the uh
creatives and the digital world the data
scientists that's the type of thing you
can do remote pretty easy
uh as far as the technical job goes but
there's zero community in that and
there's zero human touch and the
productivity goes down
uh but it sounds it sounds kind of cool
i'm at home with my kids i get to see my
kids more i'm at home more and and the
truth is the mit studies and the other
studies are coming out already it didn't
take long
for this idea of work from home to melt
down uh remote work to melt down and uh
we're gonna see a return to of those
people that made a mistake they thought
they were gonna find happiness there and
they didn't so what the problem is is
not the uh not the work from home is a
flawed system the the flaw the problem
is is that you
you thought that that was going to make
you happy because you didn't like the
people you worked with now right well
you fell in love with seeing the kids
run around you think environment's gonna
make you happy you know you just
mentioned developers we get some
world-class developers here and they
came from big big companies very
impressive resumes but they come join us
because of the contribution that they're
making they see a missional result to
their work so it's not just the paycheck
it's not just the love of the work it's
the results of the work as well and
you've got to be able to see that
because everything wears off
everything's shiny wears off so don't
take you got listen you got if you're
right now you're looking for a job
you got your choice you really do you
can just pick
okay there's there's you know there's
more people looking for jobs than jobs
and so you can
you can i mean there's more jobs than
people looking for jobs i'm sorry so you
it's a buyer's market you can you can
just choose so here's the thing
don't choose based only on money that's
right that's not gonna make you happy
don't choose based only on environment
like i get to work at home that that you
got to make a choice that's deeper than
just those surface things and get down
into the purpose of what you're doing
and plug into that and if you don't do
that the environment changing the money
change is not going to fix your life no
it will and here it is the very simple
depth of dave talking about is this
talent what you do best passion work you
love
mission results that matter to you when
all three come into alignment you're
gonna love showing up
that's how it works
huh william is with us in greenville
south carolina hi william how are you
i'm doing great dave and ken it's an
honor to speak to you congratulations on
what you are doing for america well
thank you sir how can we help today yes
well i first heard you a long long time
ago when i lived in nashville working at
applebee's and um
anyway i've realized that i didn't have
the right size shovel and so i've worked
my whole life until i have the right
size shovel i believe
but um and my wife and i've been
debt-free but i've but um
kind of in steps four five and six i've
already well i've paid for my children's
college but i've arrived at the age of
53
without
saving 15
and without paying off my house
and i'm just wondering
you know to work from 53 to 63 i don't
think 50 15 will get me there
should i should i break the money that
i'm able to save now 50 50 and do that
or should i focus more on
um
i've just never trusted the stock market
but i've you know you preach it every
day and i'm just wondering at 53 what
would you do
well we don't have to do anything in
baby step five four is fifteen percent
of your income going into retirement and
everything else going towards the house
how much do you own your home
about 500 000 okay and what's your
household income
about this between fluctuates because i
owned i had i actually had to start the
company to get my shovel right but it's
between 800 and
850 900 depending on just depends on the
year
but it hasn't already been that way
i got to catch my breath here a little
second did you just say 800 000
a year
yes sir okay
and you don't think 15 is going to get
you there
no okay well i mean well let's do it
let's do it let's do a little math okay
uh
year one you live on three hundred
thousand dollars and you pay off your
home
well wait a minute
let's pay taxes on that eight to nine so
let's call it five
is that fair okay it takes two years
and you live on 250.
why
okay i'm not why i know i'm just giving
you a hard time 55 years old your house
is paid for and you make 8.50 and you
own the company
so what is the destiny of this company
upon retirement
um
it will be sold
it's a garbage company and what we do
is um
it's really worth asset value at the end
it's there's really not a big pot of
gold the gold comes as you work it you
can't sell it while it's being worked
for this tremendous cash flow
um
no it's it's it's not it's not that type
of company i mean i know what you're
talking about you hear these big big
companies come in and swoop in and pay
you know because most companies that you
make 800 000 of your profit on you could
sell the company
well
i just i'm just i just know that people
that do what i do they sell i mean i
read the trade rags they sell their
companies for asset value at the end so
your trucks i'm really not looking not
looking for a big lick yeah trucks and
dumpsters and stuff yes yeah all right
well done
very well done well thank you love it
proud of you
um
in the old book the millionaire next
door
and there's a few other pieces of
literature out in the millionaire stuff
that uh one of the
most likely to become
very wealthy by the way is your trade
it's a it's a dirty little secret no pun
intended so um
but uh
but so okay here we go so we're 55 years
old you make 800 000 a year you don't
have a payment in the world and so how
much are we going to bank a year after
of your 500 after taxes how much you're
going to put in mutual funds
um
from that point from that point forward
because you're at baby step seven two
years from now
right
so so you're saying
pay your house off and then
save three or four hundred thousand
dollars a year mutual fund so two or
three yeah yeah i'm saying it doesn't
matter
if you flip it and do it the other way
you're still gonna get there
because you're right you don't have a
shovel you have a truck you have a whole
fleet of trucks yeah you're just
counting that's amazing so your income
is your answer um yeah just get but just
lay out a very intentional plan to say
i'm going to invest this much i'm going
to pay this house off boom just like
that
wow yeah unbelievable not to mention
what he could save from his company buy
some other assets that make money
unbelievable
man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsay show
open phones a triple eight eight two
five five two two five jesus and susan
are with us in san antonio says on my
screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you yes we are
awesomeness how much did you pay off
we paid off 46 027
months good for you and your range of
income during that time uh roughly
around 60 000. okay cool what kind of
debt was the 46 000
oh everything credit cards student loans
cars personal loans couches family loan
you know mostly irresponsible debt
and asus kind of wraps it all up
i love it
well done so you guys were like normal
very yeah how old are you guys 32
i'm 30 how old am i 36. i'm 34. yeah i
hit it pretty close almost like i've
done this before okay so uh and 46
almost 48 almost four years ago
something changed and you start on this
ramsey journey what happened
it did well we were living
i wouldn't even say it barely paycheck
to paycheck you know i joke that scotch
tape barely held
together that the end
um it was a lot of credit cards and a
lot of praying until we got to the next
month
um
and i had heard of you before you know
growing up a good southern baptist girl
we'd heard i'd heard of you before but
and i knew like the whole envelope thing
which we tried but a friend of mine was
reading the book and so finally i read
the book and went oh
that's what you do
and just
sick and tired of being sick and tired
so we buckled down and we did it
we did so jesus she comes in she read
this book and she said uh we're about to
change everything what'd you say
i didn't like it at all whatsoever i am
not the kind of likes to wait but um
mostly like anything
i if i mean somebody asked me i'm gonna
say i don't like it but i respect it
because it works and i'm gonna continue
to use it
ah that's powerful
he was so mad his doctor he had went to
a doctor's appointment and he was
brooding about it the doctor was ready
to put him on like antidepressants and
he's he was like no no it's just the
budget i don't like it man i'm gonna go
ahead and grow up and get over it
wow
i don't need drugs i just gotta grow up
i like you man this is fun you guys are
great
all right this is a long track 46
thousand dollars oh i said 48 months
it's 46 thousand dollars over 27 months
i did it wrong
yeah you didn't even correct me you let
me do that and so you did it in two
little over two years ago you started
the process and
and so what is the uh the secret to
getting out of debt you're you're pros
you did it
the budget yes budget
budget and and like rachel says it gives
you permission to spend so it takes away
that guilt
like you know you have a clothing budget
you can actually go spin that but then
tightening the budget you know quit
paying attention to where your money's
going is a huge thing because we just
ate out or we bought this or both that
and it was just whatever credit cards
yay
and when you pay attention it really
makes a difference
and once you learn to wait that's when
things really start coming together for
me it did anyway um
you know that whole adults devise a plan
and follow what children
do what feels good thing hey sis you
mentioned uh
obviously you didn't like to wait and
then susan brings this home tells you
about it to the point that your doctor
almost misdiagnoses you how long did it
take for you to go okay i i'm gonna
start
waiting and be disciplined how long did
it take effect we saw one of uh dave
ramsey we saw him live at a church in
round rock
and uh just hearing more of his stories
and more of uh the realities of uh you
know how king hawk can suck sometimes it
was kind of a turning point for me and
just i just had to buckle down and that
was like four or five months after i had
brought the book home because i was like
he's nearby let's go it's free it's
church service let's go
[Laughter]
church is free yeah you always tweet
that right before you you preach at a
church i love that oh
well because i get accused of everything
else so why not but um
yeah way to go guys i'm so proud of
y'all
who were outside the two of you who was
cheering you on
i it was mostly each other to be honest
yes
and i became obsessive with the podcast
so i listened to it quite a bit and it
kept me motivated which then i would
bring home
and it's funny how it works we both had
little moments of weakness and when i
would get a little weak she she'd cheer
me on and when she would get a little
weak i would cheer her on
the way it works in a marriage yeah it's
it when it's working that's how it works
you're right that's exactly the way it's
supposed to be we have a shared goal
and we're gonna we're gonna encourage
and hold accountable and we're gonna
lock arms and we're gonna get there
together it's a shared goal and that's
what makes all the difference in the
world we find very few couples where one
of them fights against it that actually
make it
uh they know that we did them and
they're very seldom become wealthy if
they're fighting against us so working
together is everything yeah and jesus is
susan our marriage before i was very
resentful of him and his
like like to spend money and dream of of
money of what we can do with it and i'm
like we can't pay the bills right now
stop dreaming
but it changed everything you did your
program really helped us really help on
our marriage a lot hey i want to ask you
a follow-up on what you said jesus i
thought this was really great coming off
of what dave said as well that both of
you had areas of weakness but you were
strong for each other that's really
important to be able to own that that
this isn't a perfect process
do you mind sharing
each of you really quickly for other
couples where were you weak and then how
did you come along and actually
encourage each other
you guys there
i think we lost them yeah see what
happens when ken coleman answered
at first i thought oh i stumped him
there was that time oh a minute they're
going are you guys with us
no no technical difficulties yeah
i don't know maybe uh
maybe kelly maybe kelly messed it up you
think kelly messed it up
i'm not going to say that because i'm
scared i still see him on the screen and
i can't talk to him and it's gotta be
kelly's fault it did well i'm gonna go
with that
i'm going with it it's kelly's fault oh
i'm getting the death stare
getting the darth vader death stare
that's pretty good hey i'll ask that
question of you i mean when you and
sharon started it
i mean the very first time that a couple
went through this
uh
were you weak in an area and and because
i know you like to spend you tell people
that and sharon came in and vice versa
what was that like for you all
um
you know our weakness might have been
that we were so beat up and beat down
that we were just afraid yeah
um that might have been our weakness
and so it was like lost confidence and
that kind of a thing and so she would
say yes we can still do it because i was
always the one yeah you can do the show
you can do this and then when i got you
know i just one of the things i lost was
my confidence my self-esteem
because i lost a company
we lost our income we got a brand new
baby i can't feed my family i'm 28 years
old i was crushed
and so uh one thing she did was just
lift me back up in that regard okay
kelly did her magic because she's magic
um and got jesus and susan back on the
line maybe hey guys are you there how
are you doing hey okay good sorry about
that i have no idea what kelly did to
hang up on you but um
we're sticking with it so uh hey susan
susan i i don't know if you heard the
question but it doesn't matter now
because we're out of time i want to get
you to be able to do your your debt free
scream i'm so proud of you we got a copy
of the legacy journey for you that's the
next chapter in your story to be
everyday millionaires you're on your way
congratulations a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away for
someone to start their journey way to go
you guys all right jesus and susan san
antonio texas 46 000
paid off in 27 months making 66 000 a
year count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two one where's that free
[Applause]
that's a deal right there man
well done well done well done well done
man
and we actually
technically pulled that off all in one
segment got them back on that was yeah
that's flawless phone screening for
somebody that messed it up
if dave doesn't make it back folks to
the next break i'll be here for the
break we'll still take your calls if my
body is found in a field
south of nashville oh dear people know
what happened
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and author of
the brand new book from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to getting the
career you love hey it's on sale now at
ramsey solutions be sure you jump in and
get you one while you can brian is with
us in indianapolis hi brian how are you
well maybe he's not i think we're having
a little issue here all right let's try
ellen in san antonio hi ellen how are
you
hi dave i'm doing great how about you
better than i deserve what's up
um all right so my situation is i took a
job back in july and
this was after completing an internship
there through my uh
my graduate degree
um the woman that was supervising my
internship put in a good word for me the
job that i took was not um
it wasn't directly related to social
work as far as like advancing my career
but it was similar to what i was doing
so i decided to make the jump however
i've realized since taking that job that
it's not really hitting the areas that
that light me up and
help me
do or make the impact that i'm
i'm able to make and so i started
looking for a new job
however um now that i've had three two
or three successful interviews and the
potential to take a new job
uh this place had a position open up and
my supervisor came to me and basically
said
that they are looking to to really lean
on me and my
my uh
my social work abilities in order to uh
to fill that position and
and provide like medicaid services and
connecting our youth with that
so where i'm at right now is i'm trying
to figure out if i need to stay
because
the person that i have a personal
connection with who got me in that
position
is telling me they they're going to need
me or if
i should
continue looking or potentially take one
of the jobs that i'm going to have on
the table
um
and and start doing things that are more
like case management and will
directly teach me more about the field
and advance my career in the long term
sure
well the answer is you need to make the
decision that puts you on the right
ladder or moves you up the right ladder
okay and so
this this supervisor has come to you how
specific are we talking about are they
saying hey hang in there for six more
months or it's going to be available in
30 days how specific is this opportunity
or has it been discussed in specific
terms
they came to me yesterday and they told
me by the end of the week they wanted to
start training me on it and the position
would be posted within the next week or
so
well i certainly would walk this out
because you know it's it's unlikely
you're going to have an interview or two
ready to go or even if you do by the end
of this week you've already been
interviewing right
yes i've already been interviewing and i
have two very likely job offers based on
how
how those interviews went and all three
of these jobs are what you want to do
yes so the one that would require me to
stay at my current place i'm employed uh
it's probably the least
new like it's it has no more advancement
opportunities in that direct position
but i would still be working with my
internship supervisor and and learning
some important things about uh service
provision and resource coordination
the other two are case management
positions
and i would be learning a lot more about
um that's the answer that's the answer
the other two give you much more
advancement opportunities and they're
what you want to do the only reason
you're hanging on is a relationship with
a supervisor yeah and the problems are
just too nice yeah
yeah you don't need to feel guilt by the
way i get this call a lot uh that well
they hired me right out of school yeah
it's great uh but but leave the right
way and i think you're more worried
people are more worried about what
they're going to say about us when we
leave and the reality is is you've got
to do what's right for you 25 years from
now nobody's going to remember the
supervisor including you yeah
yeah that's a good point and so you know
what is it it's not being selfish or
greedy or ungrateful or any of those
things it's you're not any of those you
don't even have that bone in your body
you're just a sweet person
and that's that's what's troubling you
is just a comma matter of conscience and
so if the supervisor and the
relationship there and the the sense of
loyalty to them was not in the picture
you take one of the other two jobs in
about 30 seconds right
yeah absolutely that's what you need to
do the the act of moving forward ellen
and for everybody listening today the
act of moving forward means we will
leave people behind and we got to get
over it leave them well be classy treat
them the way that you would want to be
treated be grateful but do what's right
for you so how old are you
24 okay
uh you got any really great friends from
high school that
uh
went down the rabbit hole and you didn't
uh yes i do yeah you left them behind
didn't you
i did that's that's what ken's talking
about
uh every one of us have that from high
school by the way we've all got someone
someone that we stay in contact with
that we love and someone that we really
thought we were gonna be friends for
life and uh we just went down extremely
different paths
and uh they either left us behind or we
left them behind or something right and
that's true when you leave leave
any kind of a thing like that including
a a former position you're you're
they're leaving you behind you're
leaving them behind whatever it is so i
i think you just go in and you do you
quit with a lot of gratitude it's been
my honor to work here what you've done
for me has meant the world for me your
appreciation of me and has made this a
hard decision
uh
and uh you take the other job
all right i really appreciate it and
congratulations ellen you've earned this
the best is yet to come go
are you gonna are you gonna do it
are you gonna do it
i really i really think i am it's
it's a hard thing
because she's she's a mentor to me and
so and you know what you know what if
she is she will continue to be
and she'll be happy for you
sad if she's i get that if she really if
she really is
because i've got i've got friends that
have worked here for 10 years and then
they left and went and did something
else and i'm sad when they leave but i
also celebrate their successes out there
and there's a whole bunch of them that
used to work here that are successful
somewhere else now and on their own
started their own businesses and i'm
really sad that they're not here for
multiple reasons but relationally as
well and uh but i'm a real mentor and so
i really still love them and i'm really
still cheering for them um
and uh
with absolutely no economic ties
whatsoever so uh that that's
that's the thing
it is hard though it is isn't it great
though that she's got that kind of
character because a lot of people don't
they just go see ya i didn't even know
this term it's like ghosting until about
a year or two like unfriending someone
on facebook you know it's like about
that cold yeah like as if they were
really a friend in the first place no
one has 8 000 friends come on right
i got four and a half million apparently
but i'm really not really that friendly
with any of them i i like all of you i'm
sure or most of you but um
but you know i i don't you know it's not
your real friend
you know you know what's going on here
and and i hear this on a regular basis
is what we fail to realize is the
psychology of what she's talking about
and the psychology of this at a base
level is that it's confrontation even
though you're not going into gripen
you're not going in with an axe to grind
but the very nature of sitting across
from somebody and you gotta go i'm
breaking up with you but it's not you
it's me
i think it is it's and so it's yucky
nobody well
i couldn't say nobody i think you and i
enjoy a good confrontation when it's
good yeah but these people
but even but a breakup i i you know
relish nobody because there's always a
tearing
there's always a tearing and so i'm not
trying you know i mean unless it's a
unless it's a violent breakup and it
needs to be violent right um but i mean
most of the time it's it's just you know
it's i
it's it's just this thing is a necessary
ending that's what it is as henry cloud
says yeah and so
yeah it's uh
but that's powerful that that young lady
at 24 years old has that deep sense of
loyalty and honor
that's powerful and uh by the way that
is a character trait that is rare enough
that it gives you a superpower it
certainly does when you have it and
here's the thing on this
you you know we talk about all the time
at ramsey solutions control the
controllables in a situation like this
where you're leaving somebody and a
company you can only control how you act
so don't fret i know it's hard but don't
fret over how they act you can only act
classy and grateful and then move on
yeah you can't you can't decide how
they're gonna be
that's exactly right
wow
ken coleman good hour
that was this hour of the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host king coleman ramsey
personality is my co-host today you jump
in we'll talk about your life and your
money the phone number is triple eight
eight two five
two
claudio is in west palm beach florida hi
claudio how are you
i'm well dave thank you so much for
taking my call sure how can can i help
so dave i started your plan a little
while ago because my wife and i when we
got married she had some student debt
and to us the six thousand dollars was a
lot of money not knowing how to do it
but we paid it off and i'm so thankful
that she had it because that got us on a
budget that got us thinking financially
smart and it put us
in contact with uh
your team and and we've followed your
principles along the way we have uh paid
off the debt and we have uh we actually
saved up a year emergency fund
just because of some you know things
we're seeing in the world
uh going on but uh i'm actually to baby
step 3b
but
being so passionate like about not being
in debt and having this freedom uh we
truly
as a family we do not want to get a
mortgage we would like to
buy a house in cash and uh we're also
very patient people and we're willing to
save over the long run so my question to
you sir was how can we do that
and is it because we don't want because
we you know we know we shouldn't just
have our money sitting in a savings
account uh so where to put where do we
park our money during this time
how much are you trying to save
um our goal is to save up two hundred
thousand dollars okay and what's your
household income
uh fifty thousand dollars a year
and so when do you think you're going to
have two hundred thousand dollars
we would like to do it um with we're
about to have our first baby so we're
not we're not in a rush we would look to
do it in 10 years or possibly 20.
well a lot of difference in those two
so what you need to do is you need to
lay out a specific goal and then start
saving an amount that gets you there in
a very specific period of time
any amount of money you're going to
leave alone longer than five years you
can consider mutual funds for that
so what's your career
i work as a as a banquet server but i
work on palm beach island so it's a pays
really really well
i bet
and so this is the combined income is is
your wife going to stay home when the
baby comes
yes my wife my wife will be staying home
when the baby comes so this is this is
my income
okay
do you have dreams do you have things
you at least wonder about as it relates
to your long-term professional purpose
uh yeah i really i really i work for
such a great company and i my dream is
to
to move up in the company and there
there has been hints um towards that i
only have been working there for not
even a year now but uh i'm very you know
i'm very diligent i'm very passionate
about customer service and and having
customers have just
like a top experience and
it you know it comes notice because
customers will comment on that so i do
believe that there's possibility that i
can move up and with moving up uh the
pay does go up as well there you go
i've heard
yeah well dave's right you guys have got
to decide what's the realistic goal here
to save up to 200 000 you've already got
a year's worth of expenses in the bank
for your emergency fund we teach three
to six months
so you know if you get serious about
this and you go hey i want to move up
but i also want to make more money so
that i can get in that house sooner i
think that's the path man and i think
you're such a diligent sharp young man
i'd get after it but i think dave 10
years versus 20 years that's that's a
long time to save for a house 20 years
yeah i think 10 years and i also think
you gotta
you know you're not gonna extrapolate
fifty thousand we're not going to just
say linear
no growth in in the right as a part of
our goal setting in our projections
we're gonna assume some kind of increase
in income as you go along yeah uh
sometimes it goes back a little and then
it comes up but overall people generally
earn more
throughout their careers because they
actually get better at it and do move up
jared is with us jared is in jefferson
city missouri hi jared how are you
i'm doing pretty good how are you guys
today better than we deserve what's up
well i'm trying to
i work a regular you know
i can't say nine to five because like i
work three a.m to seven a.m sometimes
but
i'm trying to find time to jump into
owning my own
automotive company and it just it really
scares me from going from a
strong steady thing to you know
something that
i have a lot of compassion for you know
what would be more specific what's this
automotive company is it mechanical what
are you doing
um it's gonna be mechanical for like
engines transmissions
floyd lew tires you know just all-around
general maintenance are you doing any of
it on the side now
yeah um in fact we're i'm working with
my father-in-law and my brother-in-law
too and there while i'm working my
regular job there we actually have a
building right now and
i got the name of the company
through the state all that stuff
already just
it's just
before i quit my job um
to go do this full time it's just
it really terrifies me is this no i get
it well we're gonna simplify this for
you because there's no jump involved
here so let's take this out of the
equation there's no jumping uh are you
but tell me about the father-in-law or
what's going on there just say if
partnership or is this your business and
they're gonna work for you or they're
just helping you get it going what's
that look like
um this is basically this is my business
but i just got started and they
came in and
they decided that
they'll do the
uh big work of it you know working on
the cars
while i
make the money
like with this job right now
to get things up and started great so
what do you make right now from your day
job what's your salary
uh
[Music]
it's really hard to tell because uh i
work agriculture so i drive trucks
so i bring in about what was your house
what was your income last year for the
whole year
um i actually jumped jobs since then
okay what do you think your income is
going to be in the coming year for a
year
um i'm hoping forty thousand
forty thousand dollars
okay
so if you were working this side job
with your brother-in-law and your
father-in-law working for you and your
company was making eighty thousand
dollars and you quit your day job that
really wouldn't be terrifying
i know it's just going from something
that's no no no no no no stop
try it again if you made 80 000 in the
coming 12 months on your side hustle and
you make 40 000 at your day job and you
quit your day job there's nothing
terrifying about that move
yeah
nothing i i agree with you okay so it
has to do with getting the income up so
that you don't jump
you take a step that's it you want to
step out of your old job into the new
one don't leap
there might not be any water in the pool
this
is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
well the last two years have been kind
of cray-cray haven't they
a lot to worry about out there
a lot of wondering what's gonna happen
next
uh maybe that's how you feel about your
money maybe you're tired
maybe you're stuck maybe you're
stretched kind of thin
well it doesn't have to be that way
we can actually help you be the third
pig and get into the brick house and so
when the big bad wolf blows and huffs
and puffs then you're okay right
you just need a plan
and a plan does give you confidence
the way we teach you that plan is a
class called financial peace university
almost 10 million people been through
this it'll teach you everything you need
to know
to save money get out of debt become
wealthy and outrageously generous you
can stream the lessons on your own or
you can get support by going through the
class with other people or both
and you'll put that plan into practice
with a premium version of our every
dollar budgeting app
by syncing your bank to your budget you
can easily track your spending and see
where your money goes you get all of
this
with a ramsey plus membership
and you don't have to stay exhausted and
overwhelmed you can actually win with
money to start your free trial of ramsey
plus text trial to 33 789
text trial 233-789
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com they're the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more always use the
promo code ramsey today's question comes
from drew in indiana i need advice
regarding a potential new job my current
job pays an 85 000 base
over 65 000 in commission plus i get a
company car in full benefits i have a
new opportunity that will pay 160 to 175
000 in base with commissions the first
year plus insurance and stock options it
does not offer a company car which means
i'll need to purchase one i'm really
happy my current company but the new
company is an exciting startup with
great potential in a space i'm familiar
with i keep looking at that set monthly
income from this new opportunity and
it's making me think more emotionally
than strategically how do i weigh the
variables and look objectively at this
decision good question it's a great
question and drew's half answered it for
himself
the reality is is beyond the variables
let's start with the facts this is the
good old-fashioned grandma pros and cons
list for both opportunities the new one
the one where you are now then the
variables
and then you take out all the emotions
by just simply saying what on paper
positions me best for the desired future
i want that's where you're looking at
everything not just the bump in pay but
five years seven years 10 years 15 years
20 years down the line the last step
that i would add to this is go get some
advice from somebody you really respect
who doesn't have any emotion no dog in
this hunt show them all that information
and get some feedback and that's going
to help cement what i think he'll
already know by looking at it as a
future opportunity we're making this
decision not on the now
but the next yeah the way i
help that come home in my head is i
always say and i would say to myself as
well
okay
um let's say that uh
drew is
let's say he's 32 years old okay
and say okay drew what would the 42 year
old drew be glad you did
and that makes you think holistically
not just about the income or the
structure of the income
because here's the thing
there is no
security none
your only security you know it's a
secure job that's bull there's no
security in the job
you're only as secure as your ability
to go create the income in the
marketplace
and so straight commission is no scarier
than salary
because they'll fire you from a salary
job
and straight commission they just fire
you a little bit at a time that's right
and this is a startup so they hope to
pay you that but they're a startup yeah
and so i mean straight commission is not
scary if you make 300 grand a year no
straight commission's not scary if you
make 200 grand a year nothing scary
about it because you but you you really
have the true sense of the marketplace
that you are dependent upon
you getting up leaving the cave killing
something and dragging home you have to
produce
and you're dependent upon that when
you're in a commission situation
salary
moving to the salary is a
it's a false
positive
on the analysis because it makes you
feel like that's more secure and it's no
more secure than fly the moon because
let me just tell you man if you don't go
produce more than you cost they're going
to dump you
that's right all businesses have to have
team members that produce or cause to
put someone to produce more than they
cost yeah otherwise you don't you don't
have enough money to pay the payroll
they can't pay you
so you have to make them you have to add
more value than you take out of the
equation always
or you're in an insecure position yeah
so that that's the thing here and so
drew as you're doing what ken suggested
make sure that you don't
put too much weight on the supposed
security of the salary here yeah you
know there's another uh word that's
popping up and i've experienced this
with callers beyond the security this
also feels like the smart thing to do
think about it we as humans go i've been
offered more money that's the smart
thing to do so the converse is when your
heart and your strategy are both telling
you i shouldn't do this you're going but
everybody else is going to say i'm crazy
for not taking the guaranteed more money
so it's not just security it's also it
feels smart to take the bump and pay so
if that's the version of smart that's
going around out there let's try and
let's say don't be smart that's right
instead be wise there it is that's
exactly right
wisdom is the long play if smart is the
short play yeah you know it's strategy
play the long game yeah that's
absolutely right play the long game
mary is with us mary is in los angeles
hi mary welcome to the ramsay show
thank you for taking my call i
appreciate your time
we're a little um
concerned
about our situation my husband and i are
retired we're 65
we received pension and social security
uh we have a mortgage of
probably
400 and maybe 50 60 000 on our own
we have an income after taxes of about
8 370
per month
we do pay a lot out for
our bills
we have um
one
major bill that's 28 000.
we have a balance of about 10 000 on the
car
and that's all our debt you don't have
any nest eggs
we have a 55 000 in the bank and about
41 000 and 457 between the two of us
okay
and write a check today and pay off your
car
okay but we don't want to keep that car
then sell that car today
okay you need to get rid of the debt
okay okay that's first thing that's a
quick one easy one quick win all right
and so um
what's your house payment
2400
okay with taxes and everything okay all
right
a little high but not a deal breaker
uh out of 8 300 you can pay 2 400 out of
83.70 and that leaves you 6 000 a month
to live on
you are in los angeles so you have a
high cost of living but you you know
once we wrote that check we've got
housing covered which is your big dog
if you've got no other debts because we
just started paying them off you have
six thousand dollars a month to live on
you can't live on that with a budget i
think you can even in la
but i have the twenty eight thousand
dollar bill what's that all right
uh
we consolidated
a lot of bills and we did one that we're
at zero percent interest on a credit
card okay until next late next year okay
so you need to pay that off too
okay
so if you if you sell the truck the car
what are you going to be driving
we have one other vehicle okay
so if you sell the car and got rid of
that debt and you wrote a check and paid
that off it gets rid of a bunch of your
cash but you got all this stuff hanging
over your head i'm feeling the stress in
your voice from these debts
yeah and i want to set you free from
those debts and then you can start to
live on a budget and you can actually
save money in this situation
of course the other option is you could
add income to the equation
if you guys chose to have an encore
career you're just 65.
i'm 61 and i feel fine
you're gonna be all right
hold on i want to put you guys through
financial peace university it's time you
learned this stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me 130 000 all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author of the book the
proximity principle is my co-host today
his new book is from paycheck to purpose
the clear path
to work you love it is on sale now
it will actually be shipped and
delivered in the first week of november
so if you'd like to go ahead and reserve
your copy early
you can do that for twenty dollars and
we'll throw in a hundred dollars worth
of extras
if you do that we'll bribe you to buy it
early
pretty good return on your money i mean
it's only gonna be like two weeks shut
up so we'll get the book out to you and
you'll get the audio book the e-book
you'll get all kinds of other bundled
items in there check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
with a question from san bernardino
california justin and sherry are with us
hey guys how are you good hi welcome
welcome how can ken and i help
so we're both teachers out in southern
california and uh cool what do you teach
i teach economics we actually use your
curriculum oh thank you changed the
lives of a lot of young people thank you
yeah thank you
and uh i teach i teach robotics grades
seven through twelve wow nice
so i've been teaching for 19 years she's
been teaching for 22 years and um
for reasons i won't you already know
we love our lives in california our
family's there but we i don't think we
can stay in california anymore
so we came out here we have fall break
uh this week and we came out for just
originally when we booked you know the
airbnbs and and the airplane it was just
for vacation um we're going to the grand
ole opry tonight is why i'm wearing this
silly shirt but i love it she told me
not to wear it but anyways it's all good
yeah it looks fantastic hey man you're
right in you're going to fit right in
yeah right
but anyways uh so we came out for
vacation and
a few things happen right before
our governor is crazy and stuff and uh
it
i think
it turned into more like a scouting trip
and so um
we're here in
nashville area and we're going tomorrow
to chattanooga and to check things out
in tennessee it's beautiful
the one hang up that we have is uh we
looked at the the salaries and we would
lose about a hundred thousand dollars if
if we came here per year per year
yeah they is all about seniority in
california not performance unfortunately
and so that's a hang up um
i'm 48 my wife is 46 and we'd be like
the new guy
at a job and that's we're having a
little trouble with that
and then um we do both of our folks are
there they're in their uh early to mid
70s so
i guess i kind of know i think i know
what y'all would say but um what do you
think we would say
i think you'd say go for it but i don't
know i
um
i guess i just wanted your advice and
clarity
we're thinking it's actually like a
million dollar we have 10 more years at
least to retire so it's like a million
dollar decision on income but happiness
might be more important than
well that's that's that's assuming you
would not get any raises during that 10
years that's right and that's also
assuming cost you didn't assume in the
cost of living adjustment plus we don't
have a state income tax here so i think
this is really you're taking an
emotional
decision and you're only applying the
mathematics you need to apply the
mathematics the financial but you also
have to look at the other side of this
and and that's and that's why you want
to leave and the life you want to live
and so i think you walk through the
numbers so okay let's talk about this so
do you have any debt where yet
financially with your retirement what's
that going to look like
uh well we we followed your plan we've
taught the class uh four times i believe
um we've just paid off our house last
may we have no debt we haven't had debt
for 10 years we did the the debt free of
all of our debt like maybe about 10
years ago
and so we have no debt at all we just
how much is your house worth right now
our house is worth about 450 000
okay
all right
okay and then what do you think the
salary range is going to be based on
what little research you've been able to
do here in tennessee what's it going to
look like for both of you
about 65 000
each correct yeah okay okay that's
probably pretty close yeah yeah
so 130 and you're currently making 230
between the two correct perfect okay wow
wow
okay minus 15
for
income tax right state income tax yeah
right and we've noticed that things are
yeah are the foods cheaper things are
cheaper we're finding yes
know
housing items would be different but
it's not going to be 25 different it's
going to be 10 5
here there it's not i mean it's not like
a gallon of gas is different in
tennessee than it is in california not
much anyway
the biggest issue would be the tax
savings um and the housing differences
are dramatic obviously um so
it's probably not a million dollar
decision it's probably a half a million
dollar decision
give or take maybe maybe cost of living
adjusted and tax adjusted
something like that uh over a 10-year
period of time
um and
well well you would give you'd be
getting raises there you'll be getting
raises yeah so we would just call that
yeah that's fair okay interesting that's
a lot
that's a lot
and so um i i think you ask yourself um
you know a book i wrote the worst
selling book i ever did had a great
saying in it
[Laughter]
it's called more than enough it was a
total flop but uh i only sold like i
think i sold like a hundred thousand
copies or something compared to my other
books it was a flop yeah i'd like to
point out a public service announcement
that's not a flop but anyway it was it
was a follow-up to one that sold 2
million so that's what you call a flop
so but the anyway in that book
this saying and it's a weird little
saying but it's true
only people only change when the pain of
same
where we are today
exceeds the pain of change
and so the scale is
it's not a math scale it's how much pain
are you in
there
is it enough to say
i
this is scary and there's obviously a
down it's obviously a pay cut
we can call it whatever it's going to be
a pay cut 300 to 500 000 over 10 years
are you in that much pain and you don't
have to answer that today on the camera
that's not fair to you but that's the
that's the heart question
the question your heart has to answer
um once you leave here and you go back
home
you go this is home
this is where my stuff is and it's a
beautiful state
i mean there's lots of crazy but it's a
beautiful state yes sir and a lot of
wonderful people there yes uh and so you
know and you've had great careers there
and you've got great memories there your
parents are there you can run back over
see the parents that's an airline ticket
that doesn't bother me okay we can get
back over there if they're if they're in
trouble they need some help you can get
over there that's not sure it's a three
hour flight you can be there in no time
lots of six flights a day or whatever
non-stop to la it's not
uh not a problem but uh
i got a quick question a lot of roots
coming out of the ground here a lot of
roots i want to play into this math
thing a little bit i just want to wonder
together for a moment
what do you each love if you can give me
two or three words each what do you love
most about your profession
not don't give me environment or
anything i'm talking about the work
itself what do you love most about
teaching
i love seeing the light bulb go on in my
students okay good good answer um i i
live
i teach in a 100 percent for introduced
lunch school
and so
uh
you can make a huge difference with kids
that have nothing like nothing going on
for them at all so
uh being able to see that you're moving
the needle yeah yeah i bet you are the
reason i asked that was twofold okay
number one i wanted you guys to hear
yourself say what really brings you joy
and meaning in your work and you can do
that in tennessee the second thing i was
just curious about is
you guys are young enough that you could
come to tennessee and take that same
type of work that you love and that
result that matters to you and
potentially transition into a completely
different than public education but a
career where you are training and
instructing because when i look at
teachers i look at a root word of what
they love the most and this the
functional thing that they love passion
what i call passion working love is
training or instruction would you agree
with that yes sir but the missional
result which is the results of the work
that that we all long for a mission that
drives us for you all it's influence
so where could you do that in tennessee
that's not in a traditional education
environment that wouldn't take you maybe
that long to get qualified for you don't
have to answer that i'm simply giving
you that as food for thought okay
do you start a a a simple a primitive
version of that is do you start a
tutoring thing on the side
when you get to tennessee texas or
another state it's not to be here i mean
we love our state but um
the whole point is the conversation is
not about tennessee versus california
the conversation's about what how to
make a move and how to
think through it critically and that's
what you're doing you're doing a great
job congratulations you guys proud of
you this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
brian is in spokane washington hi brian
welcome to the ramsey show
it's ryan but that's okay thanks for
taking my call sorry my bad i just read
brian on my screen because it was typed
there what's up that's right
um so my questions regarding uh
retirement um
i will have a pension when i retire it's
anywhere from forty nine hundred to
fifty five hundred depending on what i
choose for my pension plan
i'm 50 years old i got 15 years left to
work is what i'm hoping
um
and you my company does a 401k match up
to seven percent great
at a half percent
so it's three and a half percent seven
um you always talk about the roth ira
and my company offers a
rocked 401k good
but i don't know if that's the same as
the it's not the same as the roth ira it
is but
okay it works exactly the same it's
after tax dollars
going into the account and it grows 100
percent tax free the difference is yours
has a seven percent match so you're
doing this the match portion is not roth
the portion your company puts in will be
traditional
and you'll pay taxes on it and on the
growth of it when you get to retirement
so there'll be two segments to your 401k
the track taxable segment that was the
match and the tax-free segment that was
your roth and you definitely want to do
that at least to the tune of seven
percent of your income you may want to
do an individual otherwise if you don't
have good mutual funds in your 401k if
you've got good mutual funds to select
from in your 401k you can just do it all
there
okay yep and i think we do that and
i was thinking that obviously thinking
gets us in trouble but
i was thinking that if uh i'm actually
you making less money or pulling less
money out when i retire that my taxes
would be lower so
i'd be paying less on taxes than versus
now is that
not the case well the difference is this
the amount that you put in is not the
amount we worry about it's the growth
so let's say you save for 15 years and
there's a million dollars in that
account i'll just make up a number
because there would be probably okay
just for round numbers okay of that
million dollars 900 000 of it will be
growth
100 000 to be what you put in
you're either going to be taxed on that
900 000 or not
not is better than taxed
so i'd rather pay taxes now on the 100
000 and not pay taxes on the 900 000
later
okay it comes out way better so there's
uh yeah you're gonna come out
way way ahead and so uh yeah like light
years like 200 000 bucks per 100 000 or
per million dollars ahead so um yeah
definitely do the roth and definitely do
we suggest four types of mutual funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international
that's what i personally put my personal
roth 401k into at my company and i
obviously have those options available
for my team as well and they do those
that are in baby step four
uh do that as well i i assume everybody
that's doing this baby step four i don't
know i'm i don't check but
i think people pretty well follow our
stuff around here if they work here
don't you ken
yes the answer is absolutely yes all
right jerry's with us in saginaw
michigan hi jerry
hello how are you guys doing great
what's up
quick question gloria so i've been
working for this rental car company for
the last 10 years
recently one of my stores closed as a
district manager and now i have to drive
two hours to work each day leave around
six in the morning and get back at seven
that sucks um doesn't get
doesn't give me much time to look for a
job um where i'm located the reason i
have to stay two hours away is i have
seven kids two of my step kids and
they are with their dad at one week and
with us the next
we are on baby step four four five and
six
and we do have emergency fund
should i leave my job and look for a new
job in the area
um
because it's kind of a struggle i've
been working the last couple months
what kind of store is this again
[Music]
what's that what kind of store is this
again
it is uh the best rental car company
okay you guys have a studio with it okay
okay
so when you say you've been looking and
you can't find something or you said
well because of the time in the car i
don't have time to look
uh i you're kind of discounting you know
at night and we've got a job economy
right now where people are looking for
people with just a pulse
what are you looking for because i'm
curious as why you're not finding
opportunities to at least go for
so i'm putting resumes in
i'm doing that
i make about 55 000 right now with a car
and gas um per year so i'm trying to
find something somewhat equal to pay you
know food for my family and stuff so
trying to find something like that
every couple days i'll be searching on
indeed and and other stuff like that
yeah all right so so you are looking you
are seeing things are you getting
interviews
i'm not getting any interviews okay so
there's there's a i wrote an entire book
on a simple principle called the
proximity principle and it basically is
you've got to get around people that are
doing the kind of work you want to do so
if you want to stay in the rental car
game well you've got some relationships
you certainly had them before this
office was moved to another area but but
you just got to start working
relationships you know far more people
than you think you do and i can tell you
you know enough people and you've got to
say hey
listen i got moved over here it's too
far of a commute because of the family
situation here's the type of stuff i'm
looking for i've got this talent i love
doing this kind of work here's my
experience and you have got to connect
connect connect connect connect and then
an opportunity for you to get an
interview is going to pop and then they
say oh by the way put your resume in
you're just kind of playing the job
lottery right now sending out resumes
right now uh is not an effective way to
do this it never is an effort ever
we read an article i shared an article
last week on the ken coleman show where
they are saying now that 10 million
qualified candidates resumes weren't
even seen in the last 12 months
10 million 10 million so you jerry i'm
not getting on you i'm actually
encouraging you because if you start
doing good old-fashioned
shoe leather out there talking to people
and i know you're driving a lot but
that's two hours in the car where we're
calling people work the phones all the
way over and all the way up absolutely
your opportunity's just waiting for you
but it's gonna come through a
relationship yeah you're gonna have to
have some kind of a connection yeah and
you filling out applications is a
complete waste of time if you're just
doing it blindly and you're just you
know i'll give you an example okay we've
got 300 jobs on the board we're trying
to hire this year
uh we will get 23 000 applications for
those 300 jobs
you know what the chances are one of
those applications turning into one of
those jobs
almost zero
unless someone does something to get
themselves out of that pile the primary
way to get out of the pile is to know
somebody inside the building or know
somebody that knows somebody inside the
building and say hey would you ask them
to pull mine out of the pile and at
least give me a look
and uh i've even got friends i own the
company and i've even got friends who
call me hey someone says daughter has
put in an application over here and i'm
like well that's great and i i'll ping
hr and say so-and-so's daughter's apps
in the file would you pull it out i
don't tell him to hire her i never do
that but i say you know would you at
least give her a look give her an
interview and um you know the guy that
owns the company said to do it then
they'll do it or if you know sharon
calls it's even more powerful than that
um but the uh but yeah you need you need
to have a connection and listen go to
kencoleman.com download everything he's
got over there on resume templates on uh
letters to write to get in the door to
try to figure out your connectivity and
i will give you a copy of ken's first
book the proximity principle which will
get you going because that's exactly
what you need here um but you can't use
the excuse of i don't have time to
interview you have two hours a day yeah
yeah
or no four hours a day yeah and that's
not to mention after the kids are in bed
too you're emailing everybody you know
you're talking to take some vacation
time yes if you've got some interviews
that have to be done during work hours
yeah and go go sit down with somebody
because this is a time i mean you're in
a buyer's market dude yep this is uh you
you are in the driver's seat more than
ever before on getting a new job yeah
everyone is and the answer to your
initial question should you yes yes you
should this is going to suck the soul
out of your body it already is it sounds
like it's all out of my body and i'm not
even doing it yeah
dad gum two hours a day each direction
commuting it's like driving a knoxville
and back yeah
just shoot me
oh man i dropped 14 minutes and i'm
crying about that like oh man
unbelievable
there you go
that puts us our the ramsey show in the
books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage is actually an
indication that you're probably an
everyday millionaire
this is the ramsey show it's an everyday
millionaire theme hour here on the
ramsey show we're going to talk about
everyday millionaires baby step
millionaires and millionaires in general
where they really come from
a thousand years ago when i was in
college
computers were just starting to be a
thing
this is the early 1980s
and i distinctly remember one of our
computer professors and one of our
marketing professors
saying
that it is not too far in the future
that our problem will not be
a lack of information our problem will
be too much information
that we will have so much data
so many data points so much information
that we will be unable
to wade through it all and make sense of
it all
well that was very prophetic
they had no idea that facebook was
coming on the scene no idea that twitter
was coming on the scene
no idea that instagram and etc etc tick
tock etc was coming on the scene
and so now we have not only
too much information
we have way too many people that
have
the ability to give us information who
don't know what they're talking about
mainly social media but even the media
because you can just stand up a blog and
say i'm an expert
i'm an expert on finance i live in my
mother's basement but i'm an expert on
finance
uh and and so everybody seems to have an
opinion and then the thing that went
with that was this idea that your
opinion actually matters
that's an entitlement thing it's a
participation trophy thing it's a
you know so let me help you with this
uh
my opinion
about something
that i know nothing about
doesn't matter
i'm a smart guy
i built a large business i'm
work really hard
but
my opinion about hair care products
does not matter
i have no knowledge of them and so for
me to express my opinion
ferociously about hair care products
just shows that i'm an idiot
that's all it would show
it doesn't mean i'm not intelligent it
doesn't mean i don't have value as a
human being it means i have no knowledge
of that so i should keep my freaking
trap shut
but in our world today
no one does that because everyone thinks
that their opinion matters even though
they have nothing to say about it and
have no expertise on it and so they run
around mouthing off all over the
internet and you know if it says it on
the internet it must be true abraham
lincoln quoted that
so i mean this is the kind of stupidity
that's out there and so
this this leads into this whole idea
about money and wealth
so have you
heard that wealth inequality is a
problem in america
have you heard that the only way to get
rich in america is to
inherit your money
to be
a professional
sports star
or a music act or an actor in hollywood
have you heard that you know the only
way to build wealth is to hit the lotto
because
and they always say it with a wine
the little man
can't get ahead
well i've watched the little man become
wealthy for 30 years teaching what i
teach doing what i do
and observing people with common sense
and dignity going about their business
and doing what they're supposed to
getting out of debt living unless they
make being on a plan investing in their
401k getting their house paid off and
while they become a millionaire we
started calling them everyday
millionaires we were seeing them
everywhere around us and none of these
people inherited their money and none of
them were famous
and they were
devastatingly regular people
singularly unimpressive
except for the fact that they did what
very few people in this whiny but
opinionated culture will actually go do
they got up off their butt left the cave
killed something drug at home and took
responsibility for their own lives
touchdown
score
and became millionaires and they do it
really quietly and you run into them you
never know
they don't really they're not like fancy
dressers they don't drive lamborghinis
they're not billionaires they're
millionaires a millionaire is someone
who has a million dollar net worth your
net worth is
what you own minus what you owe your
assets minus your liabilities equals one
million dollars you're a millionaire
well it doesn't sound like a lot of
money well it isn't a lot of money but
it's more money than most people got
and it's not lamborghini money it's not
private jet money
but it is i'm going to live a good life
and i'm not dependent on social
insecurity
to feed me
money
because if you invest it you could have
an income around a hundred thousand
dollars a year while you sit on your
butt
okay so that's that's what a million
dollars will do for you so it's worth it
so we started studying millionaires and
then we got everybody started saying
ramsay you don't know what you're
talking about you just don't understand
the little man can't get ahead socialism
is the way
you capitalist pigs you you people have
lost your minds and you just can't do
this and you don't you're just you're
ignorant and and i kept going yeah but i
keep meeting them everywhere so we
actually commissioned a study the
largest study
of millionaires ever done and our
research team combined with some outside
research resources and did an airtight
statistical analysis of the largest
study of millionaires ever done in north
america over 10 000 millionaires studied
and we're going to talk to real
millionaires this hour
to show you what we found we didn't set
these calls up we didn't tell anybody
what to say we asked them to call at a
certain time or allowed us to call a
certain time but they're not scripted we
just said if you have a million dollar
net worth we want to talk to you
because we want to learn what real
millionaires do not what some broke
[ __ ] in his mother's basement who has
an opinion about socialism thinks
you're just a little broken [ __ ] honey
i hope you grow up and get better
but right now you're too stupid and you
should keep your opinions to yourself
because you're misleading people when
you say the little man can't get ahead
because he does every day
and it makes me angry when you convince
some little man that he can't get ahead
because you can get ahead
you can beat all the isms
and there's lots of isms out there
and they're very real
there's some ignorant people that will
discriminate against you based on
the most ridiculous of things
and you have to be you have to beat them
too
and you have to go around the morons
that do that kind of stuff but it can be
done folks i meet people of every race
creed color national origin immigrant
born north south fat skinny bald or a
beautiful head of hair who have become
everyday millionaires starting from
nothing
i meet them everywhere we're going to
talk to millionaires this hour
only
not your broke brother-in-law with an
opinion
we're going to talk to real ones and see
what they say
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's an everyday millionaire theme hour
here on the ramsey show we're talking to
real millionaires matt is in milwaukee
wisconsin matt what is your net worth
hey dave uh about four mil cool give me
a little breakdown on that how's it
mixed up between your retirement and
real estate and so forth
sure
yeah we have about 1.5 in mutual funds
maybe 900 in real estate that's a paid
for house and a piece of recreational
property that we paid cash for
and the rest 1.6 and change is in
retirement accounts mostly ross and
things like that cool how old are you
i'm 37. good well done and how much of
this did you inherit
i didn't inherit any of it dave okay
and what is the range of your income
household income from uh worst income
year to best income year
well the day that i listened to you for
the first time my wife and i made
about 50 000 combined
and in that time that was in 2007
our highest income year now was just
over 500. whoa good for you what do you
do for a living
uh she's a
sort of a corporate exec in hr and i'm a
consultant and that came because of one
of the lessons
that i got in financial peace university
the first one talked about money being
amoral
and how it's okay to go out and live a
meaningful life through a meaningful job
but it's also okay
to make money doing it and for some
reason that lesson was just never
never bestowed upon me i was always
willing to work hard uh what do you say
leave the cave kill and drag at home
but some work pays more than others but
there was there was shame associated
with making money before and that took
it away
for some reason yeah it was embedded in
there somewhere what's your degree in
my degrees in political science and
finance okay and what was your gpa
it was in the high threes three six
three seven got it okay cool and how
much of this debt i mean how much of
this net worth is there because you
borrowed money to make money
well in 2008 we called into your show my
wife and i and did our debt free screen
together with you
and that was the last time we borrowed
money we had credit card debt and
student loans and for the year from when
i first started listening to you to when
we
um
had our debt free stream i actually get
emotional thinking about this
we never borrowed again
except for the house and we paid it off
in four years yeah so you didn't become
wealthy because of borrowed money
no sir quite the opposite okay cool
well you did this really quick at 37 and
just 13 years that's pretty incredible
very very well done uh from this from
the point you said ready set go
so what advice do you give to that uh 22
year old out there listening that 28
year old out there listening
yeah i was 24 when i heard your radio
program the first time
and
the first is one you've talked about a
lot you just cannot take financial
advice from both people
or for most people because most people
are broke you have to go out and seek
out and emulate people who really do it
the right way and they're actually kind
of hard to find as you said in the
opening of your show today it's sort of
an unassuming group of people i would
consider us inside that category
um and then the second is if you're
fortunate enough to be able to get a
high income and have excess money
act for a little while like you don't
and just give yourself permission to
save a bunch and give a bunch for a
while
and you just don't quite know what could
happen from 22 to 28 and it won't happen
for everybody but where it does
it's okay what'd you pay for your last
pair of jeans
ooh not very much
25
although i have to admit that it's my
sort of a weak spot for me i do buy um
sort of like expensive hunting clothes
now so that's my that's my vice you got
four million dollars dude
it's okay
i know right it's hard to wear off
though you know like you do it for a
while it's hard no you said you said
unassuming and that's that's exactly
right yeah i'll definitely spend more on
a gun than i will assure it
hey man congratulations i'm very proud
of you well done an everyday millionaire
hey real millionaires are who we're
talking to kim is one she's in atlanta
kim what's your net worth
hey dave uh we got a net worth right now
at about 2.4 million cool give me a
little breakdown on that uh by category
so we're a little different than a lot
of folks most of ours is actually in our
retirement savings we've got about 1.8
sitting there
and then we have a house that's about
450 000 and then the rest of it is just
in miscellaneous
um mutual funds and that kind of thing
so you just loaded up the old 401k
i did i really did um
my husband
so i'm 53 my husband's 52. and so how
much of this 2.4 did you inherit
not one time zero
and your income worst year
event household income to best year of
household
income probably our worst year was
around 80 000 and now we're at about 220
to 2 30. cool what do you all do for a
living
my husband is an aircraft mechanic for a
commercial airline and i am a i work
with a pharmaceutical company and sales
ah good both good jobs good so what's
your degree in yeah
i have a microbiology degree okay and
what was your um
yeah a good use of that um yes it really
was i mean you actually know the science
yeah so the um yeah uh your gpa was what
um i think i was around 3.6 when i
graduated cool all right
so uh you're 53 years old you got 2.4
million dollars you inherited none of it
you mainly do to your 401k
um someone's listening out there this is
the first time they've ever turned on
the ramsey show they're riding along in
their car and they're going what have i
found here and the 53 year old genius
who's got 2.4 million dollars tells them
they're 25 years old a can they do this
and b if they can what what should they
do
well so i have a 22 year old son so this
is the advice we've given to him is that
while we have a wonderful you know nest
egg of 2.4 it could easily have been
triple that if we had been a lot more
careful with our money when we were
younger
and just staying out of debt
would have made such a difference for us
if we had not gotten specifically more
me than my husband i'm the spender he's
the nerd um if i had not been so
careless with you know i got a good job
and i thought i could just out earn my
stupidity so to speak and that just
didn't really work in the beginning so i
had some pretty poor money habits that
thankfully we were over to overcome
after a while but at least the one
saving grace that i had was my husband's
voice of reason saying well if you're
not going to save it in a savings
account where you're afraid you're going
to spend it at least put it in your 401k
and so we did we always maxed those out
but
really you know it's not complicated
it's just simple just to try to avoid
debt and don't
spend more than you earn you know live
below your means and when we bought our
first house we bought it based on one of
our incomes so that either of us ever
lost the job we wouldn't lose our home
and i think that was a really smart
thing that we did too
yeah
did during this time that you were doing
all this did you guys
enjoy vacations did you have a life or
did you just live in a cave and collect
lent
so i like i said i'm the spender i
actually have a very expensive hobby
that i was never willing to give up or
sacrifice and that was where a lot of my
money went i'm an equestrian so i
compete and ride horses yeah that's
nothing cheap about that
yeah exactly and then our daughter does
it as well so there were two of us doing
it
um
so we did do that and we always tried to
plan at least one vacation a year um and
we would save up for that and we you
know we tried to not use debt to do
vacations so let's let's lay out
something for yourself let's say a fact
out there because you're fairly common
fairly typical among millionaires
fact
when someone says
oh i need to yolo
you never know
right i need to i need to i need to live
now i wouldn't want to live like that i
might die later the fact is
you have had a good life
you've not lived in a cave collect lent
no never seen the sun shine
just so you could be a millionaire you
didn't trade your entire existence a
quality existence on the planet
for this money you went and had a good
life and save some money because you're
intentional that's a fact
so hey yolo
stop your freaking childish whining
[Music]
be an adult
was i unclear
this is the ramsay shop
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier
ziprecruiter is rated the number one job
site in the us by g2 and it's free so
how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at zip recruiter dot
com slash ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
it's an everyday millionaire theme or
we're talking to real millionaires
people have a million dollar net worth
or greater asking them
what they did how they did it
[Music]
don't follow the financial advisor from
broke people talk to people that have
money if you want to follow a money plan
kind of a cool idea best practices kevin
is in orlando florida hi kevin what's
your net worth
hey dave uh we're just over a million
about a million fifty thousand good for
you
all right and break that down for me a
little bit how much what categories
yeah 650 000 is in 401k ira and uh the
kids college funds
we've got about 120 000 between our cars
and cash and then our house is 450 000
but we still have a hundred and forty
thousand dollar mortgage on it
got it okay cool how old are you
41. and your price is uh 40. yeah cool
how much of the million dollars did you
inherit
about five thousand dollars a few years
ago when my grandfather passed away so
you're not a millionaire because of
inheritance all right and your
range of income your best working your
household income and your worst working
your household income
uh the range was anywhere from about
forty thousand uh now up that are about
two hundred thousand cool what do you do
for a living what do you all do
uh i'm an airline pilot my wife is a
stay-at-home mother
cool and what's your degree in
uh business cool
and uh what was your gpa
mine wasn't great it was about 3.0 in
college my wife is the brains in the
family she was close to 4.0 okay all
right good
very good cool
all right you're 41 years old you did it
congratulations you're not done yet you
got plenty of time to make this 1
million into 10 million pretty easily as
a matter of fact um
what do you tell people that are
25 years old can they still do this in
today's america and if so what should
they do to do it
they can absolutely do it and uh
the first thing is
um i'm sorry about that you cut out the
first thing is what
is you need to work hard oh there's that
yeah
work hard but enjoy life but uh the big
thing is stay out of debt i wish we had
done that sooner um we only got out of
debt aside from the house about four
years ago
once we got serious about following your
plan
but the last thing i think that's most
important is uh
we grew up catholic christian
and uh it's important to tithe
i was taught from a young age and we
carry through today that
god will always take care of you
i think that tithing is important give
ten percent of your income back to him
and uh your needs will be met and i
think that goes a long way into helping
you achieve financial freedom yeah
that's pretty cool yeah you can't really
mess up being generous
it's a basic principle because it
changes you
it makes you into a better more
attractive person
and i mean generous people are just more
attractive than selfish people i'm just
saying
yep i agree
and uh yeah i just it just and it causes
life to be better so well done
very very very well done so uh are you
are you a tv family or a book reading
family
um we watch a little bit of tv uh i'm
not a huge book reader i tend to read a
lot of technical publications associated
with my job in aviation but
my wife is a big reader she probably
reads i don't know at least two maybe
three books a month fashion and
nonfiction wow okay good very cool
very cool hey kevin thanks for your time
and thanks for sharing your story
congratulations you're doing it man
you're a hero you took control of your
life you took control of your destiny
that's how life works if you want to do
it well charlotteson cincinnati hey
charlotte what's your net worth
oh dave it's right around 1 million good
for you
give me a little breakdown on that well
i'll tell you we owe it all to you dave
for getting it for helping us get out of
debt we have 450 000 in various
retirement accounts
we have about 150 000 in a taxable
brokerage account
we have 300k in our house and we have
about 100k in cash good for you good for
you very good how old are you
i'm 50 and my husband is 52. okay
excellent how much of this one million
dollars did you inherit
we inherited zero okay
and what is the best year of your
work household income working income
best year and worst year range
uh when we first got married we made
about twenty five thousand dollars and
um recently it's been around two hundred
thousand
but um this last year and a half we've
been living off of one salary because of
covid and some medical things and that
was easy to do because we were out of
debt so
it's up and it's going back up as of
tomorrow the job the new job starts oh
good excellent very good okay what do
you guys do for a living
my husband is a director of technology
and i am a teacher
excellent
okay
and um so you have a degree in what
i have a master's degree in education
and my husband has a bachelor's degree
in communication okay and what was your
gpa
uh mine was 3.9
and my my husband likes to tell the kids
that they didn't have gpas back when he
went to school
i like that
i like that and there were no pretty
girls on campus but your mother yeah
i like this guy oh that's fun oh
so how much of this one million dollars
is there because you borrowed money to
create wealth with borrowed money
i i would say very little um we really
kind of screwed up a long time before we
started your plan 10 years ago and
really everything we borrowed just got
us into trouble so
yeah so you're basically the debt was
something holding you back not
propelling you forward
absolutely absolutely as soon as we
started your program things turned
around so it's all from just hard work
and saving
what advice do you have to the
25 year old version of you out there
well we are blessed with two kids in
that age range right now and we talk a
lot about this with them i'll tell you
the advice we gave them
so live below your means
take debt off the table as an option
don't even consider it
don't listen to broke people and invest
as early as you can
and be content with what you have
yeah that's powerful that's really good
you can fill in for me when i'm off the
air one day
great job hey charlotte i'm so proud of
you guys very very very well done
bob is in indianapolis bob what's your
net worth
uh 1.1 million sir good for you and give
me a little breakdown on that
a house uh roughly
a quarter million 401 k slash
you know savings cash about 450 000 and
then our business worth is at least 400
000 being a little conservative there
yeah okay cool how old are you uh 34 and
my wife is 32. wow good for you sir how
much of this 1.1 million did you inherit
uh zero we inherited a work ethic from
our panic
inherited hard freaking work i like it
so household income the best year and
the worst year since you guys have been
working
you know the crazy thing we've been
married 10 years and we've never made
like crazy money like you know maybe at
the beginning like 50 now
maybe close to 75
my wife is kind of a stay-at-home mom
slash that helps with the business
and so what kind of business have you
got a roofing business
ah that's hard work but also very
profitable good for you you got a
four-year degree
no sir we both actually have associate
degrees okay and so what was your
associate's degree in
uh environmental engineering okay and
what was your gpa
uh
i may have got a 3.0 it may have been
just a hair below that so that works i
graduated thank you lodi so there you go
yeah yeah good for you man
congratulations
okay in just a second you're 34 years
old you're a millionaire did you ever
think in america today you were going to
do that
you know no but we've been i've been
following you probably for 11 12 years
so just following your advice on money
but
everything you know
family wife kids all that kind of just
adds up i am so proud of you brother
very very well done congratulations
it's an everyday
millionaire
theme hour if you want to read about
these folks you can read about them in
the book we have for sale called
everyday millionaires
oh there you go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today deuteronomy 8 18
remember the lord your god for it is he
who gives you
the ability to produce wealth
and so confirms his covenant which he
swore to your ancestors
as it is today
i never dreamed about success i worked
for it estee lauder said
who by the way started from nothing
so we're talking to real millionaires
this hour
people have a one million dollar net
worth or greater it's an everyday
millionaire theme hour a lot of these
are baby steps millionaires meaning they
followed the baby steps that we teach in
financial peace university and became
millionaires doing that
not everybody did that but we'll talk to
you i don't care if you if you won the
lottery i'll talk to you
if your grandpa died and left you 10
million dollars i'll talk to you i want
to find out where wealth comes from and
i've been studying this anecdotally here
on the air with people for years now
doing this theme hour
and of course we did
commission and conduct
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in north america
and for those of you who question that
uh the research is airtight i dare you
to do a statistical analysis and find
anything wrong with our surveying
process or what we did
by the way we randomly ask people to
call in that are millionaires here and
this is what we get
we didn't
hand select or rule out anyone to be on
the air as long as they have a million
dollar net worth
alan is with us alan's in denver
colorado alan what's your net worth
2.3 million good for you give me a
little break down on that by category
okay about 40 of it's in
our house and then in a vacant lot we
got a
good buy on about 40 percent of it's in
retirement accounts and the balance of
20 is in
some non-qualified mutual funds and in
cash
cool good for you well done how old are
you
59 59 years ago i've met you several
times in various events well i'm honored
thank you good for you thank you how
much of this 2.3 did you inherit
my parents passed away earlier this year
so i got about 250 000 from them that
was enough to push it from about two to
two point three million okay so you were
already a millionaire so you did not
become a millionaire because of an
inheritance but you added to it with
that
correct that allowed me to pay my house
off oh very nice good good okay
and your best year household income and
worst your household income since you
guys have been working
since i started working i was probably
about 60 000 during my single working
years and after getting married a
hundred thousand for the first half of
it and about 150 000
combined the last 10 years gotcha what
do you do for a living
uh well now i'm early retired i had
worked at the telephone company in
california for several years what'd you
do there
uh i was various middle management jobs
of sales and marketing okay all right
cool what's your degree in marketing
uh i have an mba and then a bachelor's
in chemistry okay cool what was your gpa
for the mba
uh 3.4 good for you very cool
all right so you're 59 years old there's
a 29 year old listening that has 30
years to get where you are uh can they
do it
absolutely they can do it i would have
done it much sooner had i not made a
whole bunch of errors
me too
i think we had a lot of carbon copies
yeah he made it quicker than i did yeah
i lost it quicker
so uh what would you tell people then
the secret to getting to a 2.3 million
dollar net worth
working for the telephone company with
an mba at 59 years old this
keep putting money in the 401k even when
you're making mistakes outside of your
work in a basically losing everything
you have so at least you have a seed
base there
and if something doesn't seem right go
and ask a second opinion like your
parents
you probably would have
probably would have uh saved you 10
years of your life
yeah and not not made friends with wrong
people
yep that'll do it
that'll do it that'll bite you big time
hey man thank you for the call and
congratulations your hero you did it i
am so very proud of you i'm so proud of
you well done
okay
so today
4 million 2.4 million 1 million 1
million 1.1 and 2.3 is who we
interviewed 37 years old 53 41 50 years
old 34 years old 59 years old
none of them were 87.
as a matter of fact
none of them were even over 60.
that's fairly interesting
a consultant pharmaceutical sales
airline pilot a teacher a technology guy
a roofing company
and a telephone marketing executive
i didn't hear any nba players
nfl players
no famous actors
no recognizable household names
uh oh you have to be a genius to be well
be wealthy in america today nope no 4.0
one guy married a 4.0 everybody else was
in the threes
3.4 3.0 3.9 3.0 3.6 3.6 gpas
by the way that's the average is 3.6 of
all the millionaires we studied
no it's not 2.6 you have to have a level
of intelligence and ability to apply
yourself
i got a um
i'm still mad about it
i agree i worked 40 to 60 hours a week
when i was in college and i graduated
with a 2.97
three one hundredths of a point i'm
still bitter after all these years but
there you go is that close
too much beer too much work not enough
study
and i still made it out okay
there's no crooks none of these people
were stealing for people all the rich
people they just steal from people they
just beat up the little men you are such
a bunch of whiners out there the
wussification of america
it's unbelievable
it's just not true is the problem
if it was true
all your whining might be better off
but what your whining is telling people
that they can't do something that they
can do and you're stealing hope from
your own children
and from people you have influence over
and you ought to be ashamed of yourself
because you should be full of hope in
america today i know it's cray-cray out
there i know there's a bunch of nut
burgers running around the streets i
understand i see the stuff too i know
what's going on but you know what in
spite of all of that there's more
regular good people than nut burgers the
ratio of nut burgers is just about as
low as it's always been in civilization
there's always a percentage of cray-cray
out there it's just part of the deal
two percent of the public should be
institutionalized
they should be in a rubber room
somewhere but the rest of us are just
regular folk we love our kids we pet our
dogs
we like our spouse
yes we actually like our spouse we love
them but we also like them
isn't that weird but i mean nothing
there's nothing on television that
indicates that that's a normal thing but
it is typical
these people get up they go to work they
live on less than they make they put
money in their 401k
and they get their house paid off really
sexy
really mysterious
it's not mysterious at all it's just
common sense but common sense is so rare
that when you have it today it's like
having a superpower
it puts you in a completely different
stratosphere
from the characters that are just living
for the weekend
thank god it's friday
oh god it's monday
yolo you only live once
so be sure you spend it all by saturday
night
you little freaking four-year-old
you're four years old emotionally
you cannot get through uh you cannot
open a bag of candy without eating the
whole bag
unbelievable
zero adult discipline
one definition of maturity
is the ability to delay pleasure
and we live in a very immature culture
so just being a grown-up puts you way
ahead of other people we live in a
culture where adulting is now a verb
this is how rare it is
acting like an adult is now a verb
it's not a state of being anymore
this is where we live so can you become
a millionaire oh definitely
the bar is fairly low actually
can you be successful in this crazy
world you bet
show up smile work hard be kind work
hard
work while you're at work get off your
social media account somebody's paying
you you little thief
work
this is how it works guys it's not hard
you can do this
that puts us hour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you